hi everyone and welcome back
we're glad you can join us for a very
exciting expert panel discussion
with some of the industry's leading
experts in forensic science and criminal
justice
before that a quick reminder for a full
bio listing of our panelists
please click on the tabs at the top of
your screen on the right hand side
if you have any questions we encourage
you to submit them in the q a box
and we will try our best to get to as
many questions as possible during the
session
as a reminder the hits conference also
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits located at the top right corner
of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
without further ado it's my pleasure
today to introduce the inspirational
cross bruce bedoli
who will be our moderator for today's
panel discussion
bruce take it away
thank you b and it's a real pleasure to
be here today
virtually as we have a new world order
these days and how we meet
today's panel is to discuss how we can
increase the impact of forensic dna
we've we've been enjoying the field of
forensic dna for about 35 years
now and it has matured to a point where
it's so sensitive that even the smallest
amount of dna can be identified
with a high discrimination power with
only a few if not one individual can be
the contributor of the evidence we have
databases in many countries today that
help solve future crime
we have challenges of more complex
profiles
we have greater demand of work and
we have new technologies that are we are
considering to help us do a better job
we have brought together a panel of of
five of the world's experts from asia
and united states
and i'd like to have them each introduce
themselves starting with lorna santos
oh good morning thank you bruce oh good
morning good evening here
good evening there anyway uh it's my
pleasure to be here
i am polish lieutenant colonel lorna
santos
a dna examiner from the philippine
national police
and currently the officer in charge of
the dna laboratory division
of the crime lab well just a brief
introduction of where
where i am our laboratory was
established in 2000
and we started enhancing its capability
in 2012
and then in 2014 we acquired the
kodi's or the combined daily index
system of the fbi
now our laboratory is hand in criminal
cases we also
cater sometimes for paternity cases
but um main
one of the main cases that we are
handling
is the mass disaster identification and
of course we have a fair share of
terrorist-related cases and
right now things in we started working
on our database in 2014
so we are working on this progress and
we are looking forward to maximize
the potential of the dnas
the dna database and criminal
investigation
so thank you for this opportunity
thank you lorna porsha could you
introduce yourself
hi i'm portia lo i'm the acting director
of the
forensic center of expertise in the home
team science and technology agency or
hdx for short
i have a colleague with me today simon
and i'll leave him to introduce himself
essentially htx is quite a newly formed
statutory board in the ministry of home
affairs
that was established to try and bring
science and technology
best to the front lines for operational
stakeholders so within
hdx forensics is definitely one of the
key scientific domains for us
and our role is really to be able to
provide scientific expertise
and also bring technological solutions
to our law enforcement agencies
so under our ministry we have under
umbrella uh singapore police force
civil defense immigration checkpoints
authority as well as drug enforcement
folks as well thank you
thank you portia simon
hi good morning everybody my name is
simon i am from singapore
i think i've introduced where i came
from but the laboratory i'm hating and
the head of
htil which is the home team
investigative laboratory
uh our lab use dna to provide
investigative leads for
crimson officers for investigating
officers for them to
solve cases so that's essentially what
we do
thank you simon jeannette could you
could you introduce yourself please
good day everybody whatever time it is
where you are
my name is jeanette wallen and i work
for the california department of justice
dna laboratory
in the bay area of california
i have worked there since 1999 primarily
doing casework
and method development validations i'm
currently the criminalist supervisor of
the method development group
in our laboratory we have the state
offender
database we also have the state missing
persons dna program
and we have criminal case work in our
laboratory
and six other of our 11 labs that are
scattered across the state
thank you anything else to say
just thinking others have talked about
their database um
our started in 1990 um
our lab started in 1989 so our database
system is about
30 years old now
and that's about it that's great thank
you
jeanette tim last but not least could
you introduce yourself please
well hi everybody uh tim shelberg here
i'm coming to you from the
city of seattle united states uh i am
with the company of gordon thomas
honeywell and as many of you might know
we work globally to
assist with issues relating to
legislation
policy and law regarding dna databases
so we've had the pleasure to work and
probably over the last 20 years
and most of this 59 countries that have
set up dna database programs and
very happy to be part of today's panel
thank you
all right thank you tim so we have as
you can see a wide range of expertise
from everything from databases to
casework
and to advanced technologies so i'd like
to start off with
dna databases and how we can make them
more effective
so first would be what were the biggest
challenges
that any of you encountered in
developing a national dna database
system
and how did you overcome those
challenges
nobody wants to answer that question
i will i'm going to volunteer lorna
because i know that
the newest dna database in the region
and maybe talk about how she's uh how
she moved that forward
okay thank you team our database is
still
a work in progress so the for biggest
challenges
it it is of course the legislation part
in our case because up to now we don't
have the
dna legislation in the philippines
but what we are working on now is
uh more on public awareness
and putting it forward to the legislator
for their
sponsorship so we are
the pnp is working on this one and um
it is good to note that dna bill
is one of the priority agenda of the
philippine national police so
in case of uh for those challenges it is
we
are in the midst of it but this
is the point where in the key point
wherein
we cannot move forward the way we want
it if we don't have the legislation
but of course there are some other
aspects of
this that we are uh that we could use
because we don't have legislation but we
are using the dna
for our case work but to a limited
degree
thank you so um
i get i guess to to go a little further
on uh
there are a lot of countries that are
have databases in countries that are
contemplating having databases
and generating establishing a database
needs some sustainability
because you can do the work but if you
don't have the support from
the government or from the public may
not work
any of you encountered the challenges
or overcome those to ensure that you
have
a database that's that's sufficient to
meet the needs
of the task of typing offenders or
arrestees or
putting evidence in there
tim do you want to address that from
your experience of looking at a lot of
um
i think bruce i i you i didn't quite
understand the
you cut off for a second there can you
repeat the last part
sure it's um about how we can
develop a program that's sustainable uh
having a database but not having the
support from the government and or the
public
and the resources can make this very
difficult and what may be some
mechanisms
to raise awareness or get more support
so i i think particularly in the
the region where are today um i think
that
to to have sustainability what needs to
happen is that a lot of times the upper
levels of government are very
unaware of the how forensic dna works
how the um the databases operate
and therefore you have people like like
lorna and the folks from singapore with
us tonight developing these great
database programs
but the upper levels that provide the
budget may not be
aware of the value so i think one of the
keys
is to make sure that they're working at
public awareness
to bring the value of the database
program to solve crime
uh find missing people and exonerate the
innocent
to those upper level folks so they can
start getting the funding
figured out and planned for the future
so a lot of times you know
things as simple as what's putting on
these seminars
in your various countries uh doing
public outreach
those seem to go a long way in setting
up
the budgets for you to keep the
personnel
you need and the equipment and the
consumables to develop your database
yeah thank you tim i would also add that
metrics that can be quite useful besides
the typical things of how many
samples are in the database or hits but
what are the success stories and how
they could be cost effective
solving future crime can reduce those
who are recidivists
from committing crimes on the next
victim
who may not become a victim if they are
caught earlier in the process
so those can be quite helpful let's move
on to the
technology side on ways that we can
improve these
the types of samples we see today
because 30 years ago
dna typing was very different than it is
today
the kinds of samples have were far less
complex that we could analyze
today they're very complex so there are
new technologies such as massively
parallel sequencing
rapid dna and other analytical processes
to work on degraded samples
so have any of you been tackling
massively parallel sequencing to
address your needs
jeanette yeah so our
facility has been over the last
few years looking at massive parallel
sequencing
we've recently implemented a
mitochondrial dna sequencing kit in our
missing person's dna
program they just went live in february
with that and so we are no longer doing
sanger sequencing
um we are now um secondarily
working on implementing mps
also within the missing persons program
for
nuclear dna testing
to pair with the mido approach
that's a little bit slower going because
there are so many
things to still sort out with this
technology
the mido approach was much more simple
and the missing person's application is
a nice place to start with something
like that
we are also actually looking now at
rapid dna
and really considering that also within
the missing persons program particularly
for
disaster victim identification at sites
[Music]
you may have heard over the last few
years we've had
quite a few horrendous fires in
california
and so we would like to be able to
respond
um with rapid technology to those types
of events
um and so we are pushing along with that
currently
in our research group
thank you uh singapore has always been
very innovative in these kind of
technology so porsche
have you been looking at these advanced
technologies to address some of your
[Music]
challenges
yeah so with actually with rapid
definitely we've heard lots of good
success stories
um in other countries particularly in
areas with i think very large
geographical swathes but honestly we're
sort of still sort of um struggling to
find
meaningful ways of trying to introduce
it in that would really truly value add
to operations i mean cognitively we're
aware of the
apparent advantages of rapid it allows
us to bring signs
right to the field it can potentially
solve crimes better and
the soybean profile out notion becomes
even more appealing when
you can apply it to as jeanette
mentioned major disasters or incidents
since time is really of the essence in
order to bring you know better closure
to families
however having said that while it's a
good technology it's not a silver bullet
similar to a lot of other good
technologies
i think the value that it would bring
would really depend on your context on
your jurisdictions geography
and obviously the laws and regulations
so for those who may not be aware
singapore is actually slightly smaller
than
uh new york city right so and also
arguably less
traffic congestion so rapid for us um if
you look at it from the time angle it
doesn't really save much time you know
trying to get
your evidence from one place to another
so we're trying to sort of tackle it by
co-creating possible concepts of
operation that would be actually useful
for probative samples
where the need for you know quick
results can actually be balanced against
the limitations of analyzing
you know single contributor samples i
think what would be
useful for us also is for rapid to be
able to reach its full potential
um we would like to actually like to
work with the developers of rapid
technology to be able to better handle
interpretation of complex mixtures
definitely low temperate dna
to enhance its usability so for us i
think that would really be able to help
us push the adoption
rate to higher levels yeah you
along the same lines you you mentioned
both you and jeanette on
technologies and you know different ways
to use it
because these technologies sometimes
bring out new information
new genetic information that we've not
had to
think about beforehand such as
coding regions or snips and things of
that nature
are there any legal implications or
limitations
that are considered in any other
countries with these new technologies
that make it a an additional challenge
or that's not a problem at all
i think in the u.s
we're treading carefully
in making these changes that public
trust that we are not
generating data that is diagnostic in
any way
moving into phenotypic markers
is not quite there but it's
um it is something that might raise
flags for people
and um there may be state laws
among the different laws in california
that
address that um we have a little bit of
a
a a piece of
the california state law for missing
persons that
talks specifically to um
phenotypic markers in a database and so
moving away from non-coding regions
is um it's a tricky one because we're
gaining more information especially for
investigative leads
to use phenotypic information
particularly in a missing person's case
would be beneficial so i think that
it's it's to be determined as we slowly
move forward
certainly with codis in the united
states
they've recently last summer accepted
the use
of the precision id kit with the s5
but only for the coding
so the the remaining information will
um need to be retained internally within
laboratory systems
yeah that's an interesting one because
i'm not sure it's actually because of
coding non-coding
but what codis typically handles right
now and that
that may be more of a functional reason
than a coding
issue but it's interesting because you
bring up the phenotypic markers
and phenotype has a wide range of
meanings
and most for scientists phenotype gets
into cancer
risks or you know diabetes risks or some
other factors
but then when when we talk about
phenotype we're talking about things
that
everybody in this panel for instance has
already
given up that privacy because i can see
the eye color and hair color except mine
of course
has easily given so we know what your
eye color is
so you have no privacy because you gave
that up your hair color and of course
those in asia are not very polymorphic
for hair color and eye color
so it becomes less informative but for
europeans it seems more informative
are those really markers of risk and
phenotype
as you would be thinking of what
phenotype may have been meant in
other legislative acts
yeah in california
when that law was written it was 20
years ago
so things have really changed and we've
actually tried to amend it a few times
and
we will try again
because you think about it on a very
gross level
why why chromosome typing why str's is a
phenotypic
marker but apparently men don't have the
same
rights of that as others or or actually
more crimes than anybody else as well
does open up an um of where does
phenotype draw the line
and where is it considered okay and i
still think there's a long way to go in
that area
um are any of the other
countries looking at phenotype bruce we
as far as the legal structure goes we've
not seen
many of any countries really go deep
into
regulating that through legislation
but what we've advised countries to do
is is we've used the term forensically
responsible so if you're developing kits
dealing with uh outside of the normal
sdrs
that that we use um
you know these particularly in ngs
making sure that you're only developing
uh products that have the limited amount
of things in which you need
to get to your answer because if you
have a if you're collecting a massive
amount of data
that you're not going to use for your
investigation you open yourselves up to
uh
public policy scrutiny uh on privacy so
those are that forensically responsible
use
of uh of ngs and phenotypes is
the term that we yeah um
yeah tim i think i think you've raised a
really good point on two levels
one is we tend to see the these
uh other markers meantime markers become
more of
a concern if they're being placed into
databases
but if they're being done one-off on a
case
there seems to be less concern has
anybody experienced
that as the challenge that
if you just had a case and you needed to
find a lead
that there's less less
confrontation from the policy makers or
the public but if you're going to put in
a database then the
the heightened awareness um puts a
greater demand
well i throw that out there since no one
wants to answer that question
but open up another one i can make just
a quick comment about it in the united
states it seems
that when people want to go that
direction they are outsourcing that
evidence to private companies like
parabon
and then it is used in an investigative
lead
format and so i think it doesn't end up
in the courts
because of that and it doesn't get much
legal scrutiny i i think there's
actually been a case now where the
the data have been used in a court case
in the u.s
and that so it's just starting i think
in that sense
but it does bring up a conflict that tim
raised
in that um he just said forensically
responsible
markers don't do a lot of that other
information
but when you're doing this genetic
genealogy
you're actually typing the entire genome
or close to that
depending on the approach so now you
have all this other
extra information does that pose a
concern
i i've got the feeling what is in the
u.s but
would that be a concern in singapore or
the philippines if we
start typing the entire genome and
either
a private organization or the government
uses that information
what i think of four cases like here in
the philippines
if we talk about phenotypic markers
color of hair eyes then
that would mean it would be forensically
not so
uh informative for us now what we are
interested in this uh
ngs or for these uh phenotypic markers
are those markers that would that would
distinguish
the ancestry or the ancestry information
uh markers that we could utilize for
asian region particularly in the uh
southeast asian where
we all look alike and then we have this
problem with the
identifying um
an unknown person related to basically
uh
in recent years our concern is on
uh terrorism activity and we don't know
and we
it would be very important for
investigators
to determine whether that particular
person
is a filipino or from another
southeast or asian countries so for
forensically speaking
and for identification we would like to
see a
philosophic markers that would um
that would that could effectively
make a distinction between uh
a very not so different uh
not so different people like uh unlike
let's say okay i am filipino bruce is uh
caucasian so definitely if we have
markers that would could distinguish
that okay that would be interesting but
filipinos uh i think
all of us has have black hair
and all of us have the same color of
skin so yeah
it's more of um
the ancestry aspect of the markers that
we are looking into
but it's more of for investigative lead
thank you so much um
along those lines you know we've talked
about new technologies and of course
that's one part of it
but the the um standards the guidelines
keep changing and updating and the
requirements are there
uh these there are new demands and
criminal investigations
that uh also bring challenges to us how
do you keep up
with these demands i mean i know in our
work
there's always more work to be done no
matter
how many cases we do there's a lot more
so
how are you trying to address these
things uh
in the process to make it better for
your laboratory not
you know you have only so many people
you have only so many resources
and yet the cases are coming in and
there are more cases
coming in touch samples are coming in so
how are you taking these uh new
challenges
and embracing them to meet the demands
of your stakeholders
simon porsche
okay i think the important thing for our
laboratory
the most important thing is having very
clear communication
with the investigator and understanding
how the case is
being so as we sleep investigator we
want to understand the case nature
if that is required for them for
obtaining very quick investigating leads
we put them on the priority list and we
try to get results for them within the
day if possible
and so that they can pull up that lead
to solve the crime
but we communicate with the investigator
to realize
that it's not almost important we would
then
not prioritize that case and put it in
our routine
case analysis so that's how we go about
so important is still about
communication with the investigator and
understanding the case
nature and making priorities based on
what they communicate to us
so yeah so so you have a good
communication with the law enforcement
investigators to make those decisions
is there any prioritization on the type
of cases
or the number of samples that one would
analyze
i mean for instance we could have a case
with 500 samples
we could have another case with three
samples
you obviously three sample case you take
the whole case 500
puts a demand on the lab do you limit
the number of samples and put
more um responsibility on the
investigators to
help define what samples should be
analyzed
um so again going back to about
communication if you have
a number of exhibits uh i i don't think
we haven't received 500
but if there are many many exhibits
coming in many evidence items so you got
to ask the invest
investigator which are the items you
want to prioritize you just ask them
what the top five items do you want to
examine
we use that as the benchmark and we will
make a decision to process those
first and immediately when we get a
result instead of giving a formal report
we will give them an email or phone call
to tell them what's the results or any
outcome
yeah so i know in my laboratory
which i'm i'm not sure but i'm expecting
it's about the same where
sexual assault cases are huge in the
united states and there's a large number
of them
and we tend to prioritize those over
touch evidence or
breaking and entries or high volume
crime are people having the same
experience
in their laboratories um that you're
prioritizing by the
type of crime that is because of the
nature of the violent crime over the
high volume or you just doing all cases
as they come in
in caliber with the department of
justice we're doing all cases as they
come in but they're
sorted into different workflows and so
in particular for the sexual assault
cases since they cover
roughly half of our intake we have
specially designed programs throughout
the state for the department of justice
lab
territories or counties where we have
cases coming directly from the hospitals
to the lab for only
three items of evidence and a reference
sample
in a envelope that's all pre-formatted
and then the rest of the evidence goes
to the law enforcement agency
and so they are the nurses are selecting
the three items they feel are the most
promising from that particular case
to send through that direct from the
hospital to the lab
program and so our majority of sexual
assaults come
through in that format and then murders
and
burglaries they're all worked separately
in their own workflow
particularly the burglaries we even
break those up
between neat stains and touch items
you know sorry yes
we prioritize
we analyze we analyze our specimen as
they come in just like the uh
just like what um jenny said but
for our cases we do not limit the number
of
samples that we examine although we we
talked to the investigators let's say
they
they they gave us us so many um
specimens or so many evidences and then
them and point out or ask them which
are their priorities now it's
prioritizing
um in their case what is the most
provative
evidence in that particular case
now for
now for um what
so for other cases
for touch dna and sexual so just like
the
uh just like i i think most most of the
lab most of the cases
will fall into the sexual assault cases
we have this
suffering uh separate workflow for
for that and we include the ystr markers
for those
sexual assault cases but other than that
we do not uh we do not reject or we do
not
limit the submission of the evidence by
the law enforcement agencies
if you had your choice would you do that
i would no um
sometimes no i mean i think it's
it's more of educating the uh
investigators
and the uh the crimes in investigators
i think uh the life of the cases depends
on the
first person who examined the case who
examined the crime scene because
we only depend the laboratory only
depends
on their inputs so if they give us
garbage then garbage in garbage out so
it's more of um i mean
making the investigators or making the
crimes and investigators
aware of the importance of what they are
doing and the uh
the the effect of that in the uh
in the uh in the case that they are
hunting which is
i think i've been doing this
uh work for for so many years
and there are so many cases that
it is the investigators or the crime
scene investigators who would really
determine
the outcome of the case we only help
so so along those lines i mean it's one
thing with a bunch of scientists getting
together and talking about dna
we have some fundamental understanding
amongst
all of us what the words are the lexicon
and so forth
how how do you educate
an investigator who
knows his or her field very well
but now trying to explain the
fundamentals of dna
what do you tell them to get them to see
the way you see things to help
have some sort of input and feedback
to improve the process
well it's not easy because you know uh
we have a very limited number of people
working in the lab
and at the same time we are also being
tapped to uh
provide lectures now lectures for
investigators
because we have this um a sort of
continuous
professional education within the
service
where in all investigators we will take
this certain course and part of their
curriculum
is the criminalistics that's the time we
uh
we inject the idea of the importance of
the
criminalistics or let's say the dna in
their investigation
so uh investigating um teaching them
and making them aware of the importance
of what they are doing is not easy
sometimes it it's more of the uh
the the the commitment of a person
so it's a little complicated thing for
me
sure sure i i i agree wholeheartedly
um but at the same time we also have
other players in the legal system be
beyond the investigators which are the
judges and the lawyers
lawyers for both sides does anybody have
programs that they
interact to help educate these people
and what are the challenges that you see
um
communicating with the lawyers for
instance other than the fact they're
lawyers
yeah that's supposed to be a joke
i got it yeah you're supposed to i mean
on a communication level there's there's
some challenge so let's take the united
states system it's an adversarial system
where the two sides actually sort of
attack each other or argue with the
truth
hopefully the truth emerges so there is
a reluctance sometimes to share
information with with the defense side
from a laboratory because then the
defense may use it
to attack the scientists or the other
approach which one i'm an advocate of
you tell everybody everything and just
let it fall where it may
so we find some reluctance in the
education process
just wondering maybe a porsche do you
train the um or talk with the
prosecutors and judges and
what kind of relationship do you see the
communication or the challenges
yeah actually i mean now given that we
are mainly using str technology i don't
think we've had a need to sort of
revisit that conversation with the
judicial system of the courts with
prosecution or maybe even defense
but if really there's a need to and
earlier we were talking about moving
into non-str-based methods
then definitely we need to actually
thoroughly engage them and i guess short
of a
better word educate them on what the
technology can do its limitations
and to really do so in a way that can be
easily understood
but just coming back to the the part
where we were talking earlier about you
know moving into ancestry prediction
phenotypic prediction i find that i
guess most
and i'm talking about investigation
officers today they're not always
necessarily okay with
the potential of these new methods and
so when they submit samples they may not
actually be asking them the right
questions or requesting for the
type of analysis that can yield them the
most valuable information
and the reason why i say this is because
the laboratory that we run
most often times we actually receive a
lot of touch samples
and so it becomes really crucial um when
the nature of evidence that we
are dealing with is is falling in that
realm and so the examples are methods
they are not commonly used but
we are slowly trying to adopt them short
of
implementing it fully are things like
ancestry uh hopefully also moving into
things like facial morphology and
definitely age estimation
so these are all for us very useful
investigative leads that
in the event that you cannot actually
yield a match in a database we
think it would still be useful for our
ios
what i'd like to do is uh maybe revisit
something and address this to tim
because he's had a lot of experience in
the area
the aussie's databases provide a lot of
success
because when we don't have a a suspect
this gives us a chance to identify the
donor of a sample
what are the best ways to improve the
success rate
of databases and after what are those
what are the
legislative challenges or legal
challenges to be able to take advantage
of those best ways
sure well um
obviously the big
the big answer is the hit rate right so
how often
when you have a serious crime such as a
stranger rape
homicide and you don't have any evidence
and you want to take the dna from that
crime scene
and put it in your database and see if
you get a match how often does that hit
so what is the hit rate and the
high hit rates that we see obviously
united kingdom is
in new zealand are known to be the
highest have uh
at rates that hover somewhere between 60
and 70 percent
um then you'll have countries um
uh that will uh like the country of
chile
uh that only takes and the reason the
hit rate let me back up the reason they
hit rate of those
countries i just mentioned are so high
because they take dna from everybody not
just convicted
but everybody arrested but a country
like chile which only takes
people that are convicted of only
seriously violent crimes
their hit rate falls below 10 so
if you really want to solve crime with
your dna database
of unknown suspects you got to put more
people into your database and
what policymakers around the world have
seem to have agreed on
is that anybody convicted of most crimes
that seems to be okay for everybody
and that will get you a hit rate over
time of somewhere
30 to 45 percent but to go to that next
level where you're getting the hit rates
up towards 60 70 percent you have to do
the arrestees
and that raises debate and the debate is
on privacy is people that shouldn't be
arrested
are convicted of a crime should they go
into these databases
um i tend to explain to policymakers
that it's it's like a fingerprint
and if you can take that dna sample and
uh or that profile
and and get rid of the biological sample
it becomes more like a fingerprint
because governments get worried
about people looking at that biological
sample that being in the possession of
government
so i think the privacy issues to allow
more people to go up
into the arrestee category i think we
need to take
privacy protection such as destroying
the biological sample
because that makes members of parliament
members of your congress
much more comfortable from taking to
that second category of rsd
which really does drive your hit rate
and solve more crime
great so so again um more more
cases um types of uh cases criminals
arrestees and that
would improve the process substantially
make it more cost effective
absolutely i mean there's actually
studies out there showing that you know
the
more you increase your database the much
more money a government can save
because of the time wasted on
investigations and things where you
could
basically identify your suspects uh with
one simple test have any of the other
panelists have to create such metrics to
show the cost benefit of your databases
no one's raising their hand means you
don't have to do that okay
i know that they exist and sorry
i know they exist in california i don't
know what the metrics are
per se um the numbers themselves
but we went to all arrestees um with all
felons
in um 2009 and our hit rate
have doubled yeah so so the more people
you put in the higher the rate becomes
you might expect if you had everybody in
the in the country in the database you
had 100
hit rate or close to it but obviously
we're not going to do that
for lots of uh personal privacy reasons
and economic reasons
as well but it would increase it the
more you put people into the database
the um in our daily labs
we encounter problems that have to do
with workflows but
things like contamination sample
switches
have you had to deal with those issues
and put in
more restrictive policies or practices
to reduce the chance of contamination
handling in that then you had to say you
had done when you first opened the lab
and what some of those practices be
i i think one key thing that laboratory
should be doing
is implementing robotics because there
are far fewer mistakes
as a result of robotics of course you
can have contamination issues
related to those but there are ways to
solve that
so let's talk about a different kind of
automated
system to some degree probabilistic
genotyping
so for for many years we've used a
binary system
i was involved in all that binary system
development
to interpret your evidence once you you
had the evidence and you
evaluated it eventually you compared it
to some sample
and came to conclusions of inclusion
inconclusive
or uninformative or exclusion
and now we have tools that can
enhance your capabilities to interpret
the evidence
has anybody in asia and singapore or
philippines
looked at these tools yet
or better yet are you considering
looking for the at these tools
lorna you look like you want to answer
i don't think we're here
i think you're you must still be muted
can you hear me okay oh yeah i
don't need now for probably yes we are
considering that
probabilistic genotyping all those
programs that we could
we could employ and help us in
interpreting the data
but for for
now yes we are considering that but the
interpretation of the data tends to uh
favor the uh suspects so
i think our leaning is more on this um
conservative conservative
interpretation of data so
so what do you mean that the
interpretation tends to favor the
suspect
you mean it just gives more powerful
i mean no no i mean uh for
probabilistic genotyping that would aid
us in
the convoluting mixtures which is a
common problem for
dna laboratory and if we have uh if
if you could the control they can't
believe that complex
make sure then that would mean uh
more more um success
more successful identification of the uh
evidence but yes that's why we are
looking into that
but for now we our existing uh protocol
is we i think the uh the default is
make sure that you are interpreting the
result correctly
and not putting someone else and not
putting an innocent person in
not putting a behind bars so to speak
but uh
yeah if the question is considerably
if we are considering it then yes quick
answer is yes
jeanette you have experience with um
privacy genotyping in your lab have you
used it yourself
i have i actually was training on our
first version
2.0.6
several years ago when i then
kind of moved along and stopped doing
casework i
um eventually but
i will say during so we're on to our
third validation right now we're
validating the 2.7 version
in that initial version we found
that the we did a small study among
five analysts and we found that the
reproducibility of the interpretation
results
was much tighter with star mix than
with our binary manual processes that we
haven't
had in place at the time
so i i definitely have found that it's
not
faster than in a lot of cases and what
we used to do this is not true for some
people but we had
tools developed internally to run
two-person mixtures through
which ran very quickly so there wasn't a
lot of
manual hand calculation but it
um for some people it does speed things
up and for other people it does not and
um i'll just quickly say also going back
to the
integration into the legal system of
something new
that has been a challenge um across the
country for people as we've had lots of
admissibility hearings and
um the legal system has had to become
familiar with likelihood ratios which
were not popular
in the united states and in california
we have not had a systematic approach to
this it's been
pretty piecemeal just you know taking
care of it as it
turns up yeah well of course the u.s
legal system is unique and i don't
don't wish it on anybody per se but um
every technology that goes in goes
through the same legal challenges
no matter whether they're small or large
in the process
in our hands we've found that the
technology can be quite helpful
for the more complex samples in the
process
and there have been legal challenges
that we expect but we found that
most of the time problems come up it
hasn't been in the software
and we're looking at star mix as the
software as well
it's been in the user not in the the
software because
if you understand the software you can
interpret the results properly
but the users sometimes don't do the
things that they should do
and it causes problems which gets into
the
education of these new things so
as we go into likelihood ratios and
probabilistic genotyping
and of course you've done it in
california but
how are how is singapore going to
get that knowledge that it needs to
understand this
this more complicated way but more
helpful way
to interpret evidence do you have any
ideas simon or portia
simon on how you're going to figure that
out
well um at present we uh you know i'm
thinking of
evaluating adrenal probabilistic
genotyping software
but i think traditionally the courts
understand match association especially
for mixture
uh we've been using combined probability
of exclusion
or some form of likelihood ratio if it's
a two person mixture
so moving on to software i think the
challenge for us
is really understanding the algorithm
that goes behind it
and how do we calculate all these
statistics so going to the court if you
don't quite
understand how the software works at the
background or the logarithm and
sometimes it gets
very complicated to communicate that to
the lawyers to the charges
it's going to be a huge challenge so i
think education is one thing
but letting the user because we are not
statistician by training
we are not experts in it and sometimes
we have to be very dependent on a
software company
in what they could reveal some of the
logarithm or proprietary
so the extent it could tell us and even
the extent we can understand
is going to give us a huge challenge so
by just
accepting what the software does and
just going to court and if the court
asks more questions regarding the
software we may be stumped
so i think this is a huge challenge for
us to overcome
yeah and you do bring up a point there
there's two types of software the pr
proprietary and which you get from the
commercial companies
and the open source
if you have your choice which would you
prefer
uh i would i would think open source
would be a better approach because i
think there's more transparency
so even the court can scrutinize if
there's a good software
it's good a logarithm being used
so i think that that would be more
apparent that there'll be a better way
to go forward
could it be i mean one of the concerns
we have with the open source is
that the quality of the software may not
be as good or validated
as the commercial software in theory
could that be a limitation from the
legal system
concerns i mean right now we are in the
face of evaluation
so it's it's hard for me to really give
a verdict on this
so until we get more experience with the
software then i think i will be able to
give a better take on this
oh great well maybe when we can fly
again i'll come out to singapore and
we'll
give you some lectures on uh
probabilistic genotyping
in that if i'm lucky um
we have i think we're near the end um
it's
i think we have five minutes or are we
done b
i think the bruce i think it's we're
supposed to be done uh
four minutes ago so i i think oh then um
i'm not going to ask any more questions
but i was going to ask you all if you
had questions for me but
too bad next time i really want to hope
all of you for
all that you've done and provided to get
people to
see the kinds of challenges and that
there are ways to
improve what we do and make our tools
better
to help serve society so i want to thank
all of you and b
and thermal fisher for putting on this
virtual symposium and hopefully we'll
have more
in the near future thank you
thank you take care everybody thank you
thank you and a big thank you to all the
panelists
that was a very interesting panel
discussion and it went
everywhere we will now be taking a 25
minutes break
and i'll give you a chance to visit our
exhibits and application halls
we will start the next session at 11 15
a.m
singapore time 12 15 p.m japan korea
time
and 1 15 pm australian eastern standard
so i'll see you then
bye bye bye bye
bye thanks everybody take care
and